bravo à vous et on accueille en direct
Vladimir fait de Roxy bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous rejoindre ensemble
on est ravi de vous recevoir vous êtes
auteur de ce livre qui sort cette
semaine Poutine l'Ukraine les fast
cachées c'est aux éditions ballon et
justement vous allez nous aider à y voir
plus cher
et vous vous avez connu Vladimir Poutine
vous allez nous aider à y voir plus
clair sur la personnalité
qu'Emmanuel Macron il Vladimir Poutine
se sont à nouveau entretenues hier
pendant une heure est-ce que pour vous
c'est discussions ont un sens où est-ce
que Vladimir Poutine ne comprend que le
rapport de force de force et ça ne sert
à rien de discuter avec lui pour les
rapports de force c'est la vérité pour
pour cela vous faisez peut-être remarqué
que j'étais en supporter passionné de
marge du président Macron parce que
vous avez vous connaissez mon père était
un très grand ukrainien il était en
Europe de la guerre et dans ma famille
il y a 11 personnes qui ont péri la
majorité à Stalingrad majorité ukrainien
sur le front vous comprenez pour moi
c'est un déchirement en plus je
travaillais avec gorbacho pour pour la
paix la liberté tout est bougie
maintenant
alors vous comprenez dans ce livre j'ai
comparé les crises aussi j'ai donné les
clés pour te chiffrer les crises et
j'étais effrayé jusqu'à quel point cette
crise est beaucoup plus grave je
considère que cette situation c'est la
plus grande grave crise depuis la
deuxième guerre ça va sans dire mais
ça peut déraper un emporte quel moment
et le seul contact le seul contact
occidental qui reste qui nous reste
c'est le président Macron il n'y en a
pas l'allemand il a le chancelier le
nouveau il a fait quelques maladies il
aime ça ne passe pas et il faut avoir
beaucoup de courage vous êtes ému nous
sommes tous émus moi je suis bouleversé
vous comprenez il prend le téléphone
d'après mon calcul 16 coups de fil c'est
pas le coup de fil c'est parfois deux
heures puis 1h30 tout ça c'est c'est une
c'est une c'est une démarche d'une très
grande courage et de tromper vous c'est
la seule possibilité nous avons trois
maintenant possibilité de vendre la
première c'est la guerre mondiale tout
le monde parle hier Poutine il a parlé
de la guerre et les Américains parlent
de la Guerre mondiale tout le tour de
l'utilisation des arbres trempent il a
fait un cambec il a parlé de
l'utilisation des armes c'est banalisées
et vous comprenez au fait je n'aurais
pas dû faire sortir ce livre maintenant
si je ne t'ai pas si inquiet
les approximations dans l'analyse et ça
peut déraper ça c'est le premier
solutions de la part de qui de la part
de tout le monde
je n'ai pas le temps
pour taper on peut sur Poutine vous
comprenez il y avait une phrase il y a
trois semaines exactement
le président américain il dit j'ai eu
deux choix
là l'appui sur le bouton la guerre
mondiale et les sanctions de rustiques
vous tirez la conclusion comme moi qu'il
a choisi les sanctions drastiques les
Russes ils ont tiré dans notre
conclusion ils ont dit il a le choix il
a hésité et 15 minutes après Poutine il
a mis en état d'alerte c'est force
nucléaire qui peuvent nous emmerdir
plusieurs milliers de fois vous
comprenez c'est c'est les choses comme
ça je peux vous donner des erreurs
diplomatiques
vous comprenez pourquoi je suis
bouleversé et franchement vous comprenez
mes livres j'ai un million d'exemplaires
sur Saint-Pétersbourg romans San
Petersbourg j'aurais pu continuer mais
je vous fais ça spécifiquement sur les
sanctions je vais vous dire moi je parle
tout le temps avec les Américains il me
disent
les russels vont vivre mal les
oligarques ils vont faire le complot ils
vont virer Poutine aucune indication ils
ne savent pas comment ça fonctionne il y
a pourquoi cette techniquement le coup
d'État en possible j'aurais pu vous
raconter parce que j'étais pas paroles
des anti-putistes contre le coup d'état
le problème là-dedans c'est le problème
d'origine il faut j'ai dit en très
grande américain qu'il faut qu'il
résiste le Story il m'a dit non non il
faut qu'il lisse le stock parce que
pourquoi parce que vous comprenez il y a
une résilience c'est un truc banal soit
il signe
les Russes ils ont vécu 10 fois moins 10
fois moins bien que ce Poutine ils vont
perdre la moitié de leur pouvoir d'achat
maintenant je vous prédis ça mais
simplement le répercussions je ne
voudrais pas vous refrayer si les gens
nous regardent mais vous comprenez si on
continue comme ça les répercussions sont
inévitables et on va fermer le robinet
on est en train de filmer aujourd'hui le
robinet de pétrole et on va fermer le
robinet du gaz les ruches on pousse les
Russes dans les bras les Chinois il
réoriente leur économie mais l'influence
disons sur l'Allemagne surtout ce sera
l'influence gigantesque
vous comprenez je suis pas certain que
même ici les gens vont supporter le gaz
du foie plus cher mais surtout c'est le
tombeau de neige
sur un retournement de l'opinion russe
contre Vladimir Poutine ça ne se
produira pas
ce produit je vais vous dire pourquoi
mais simplement je voudrais pas qu'on
vit dans l'usure vous savez
historiquement j'étais cofondateur dans
des premiers partis démocratiques en
Russie je suis lié avec ces gens-là mais
simplement j'ai organisé personnellement
les manifestations de 300
000 personnes à Moscou 3e à la fin du
communisme aujourd'hui c'est 10
personnes c'est c'est les gens courageux
c'est parfois des centaines courageux il
protège contre la guerre mais simplement
ça touche une pour l'instant une
minime partie de la population mais il y
a un fléchissement depuis quelques jours
je constate en fléchissement et c'est
pour ça que je pousse vraiment avec mes
tripes à la fois comme craignant et
russe et européenne si on permettait je
pousse cette solution de la sortie de la
guerre le sénateur a l'air et la raison
par le haut il faut se pourquoi il faut
il n'y a pas d'autres choix il faut
sortir de ça et organiser très
rapidement le rencontre entre
Zelinski présidentielleinski président
Poutine elle est possible cette
rencontre c'est la seule solution
c'est la seule solution sinon c'est
nécessaire nécessaire pour eux vous
savez parfois je fais je suis tellement
bouleversé que je fais les appels et
avec motion
l'autre jour a une très grande télé
américaine je dis au nom de votre frère
qui est périt
à la pendant le blocus de Léningrad
autrefois quand il y avait un milieu de
personnes au nom de 27 millions de virus
qui ont péri pendant la guerre au nom
des miens il faut il faut aller mais
elle inscrit ils sont perd les tétons
grand combattant de la deuxième guerre
mondiale et vous comprenez il vient il y
a la base pour ça parce que on aurait dû
arriver franchement
on aurait pu arriver à ça pour être
franc pourquoi parce que
Zelinski il parle maintenant de statut
il peut accepter le statut neutre de
l'Ukraine
et c'est l'intérêt national grenier
parce que l'intérêt national ukrainien
c'est pas du tout d'être faire de lance
de la politique
peut se contenter de ça je mets des gros
guillemets à contenter évidemment
je m'excuse si on exigence son exigence
sur les provinces prorus
en exigence principale c'était que le
crâne il dit il s'a formule ne soit pas
anti Russie anti Russie c'est-à-dire
faire de lance contre le contre la
Russie mais je vous dis qu'on me
craignant vous savez l'intérêt de mettre
la main sur l'Ukraine et en sortir
je vais vous dire il y a des gens
notamment les Américains me disent en
carrière ils m'ont dit nous voulons nous
voirfghanistan là-bas nous voulons il y
a ambassadeur français sur avec moi sur
le plateau qui a dit nous allons nous
battre à Kiev jusqu'au dernier et vous
savez j'étais gêné
le temps il va battre se battre qui est
jusqu'au dernier ukrainien parce que
vous savez c'est les morts attendez
c'est moi je suis ukrainien car je vous
dis il y a cette possibilité et je pense
et j'appuie je sais que les Américains
veulent transformer ce conflit en sorte
de prélude de la chute de la Russie et
de Poutine c'est c'est aussi un danger
pour moi parce que vous comprenez Si
leur logique est vrai si on pousse les
Russie d'eau au mur avec beaucoup de
morts etc etc dans ce cas là ça peut
être beaucoup plus dangereux que vous le
pensez parce que ces gens là ils peuvent
dans ce cas là aller dans la détresse
jusque l'utilisation vraiment il y a des
armes extrêmes pourquoi
il faut qu'on je ne voudrais pas entrer
dans le détail parce que c'est beaucoup
plus il faut voir très clair parce qu'il
y a autour de ça il faut faire parce
qu'il y a la guerre des suppositions et
de la propagande mais en revanche garde
c'est tout à fait possible c'est
banaliser et dans ce cas là vous
comprenez il a dit encore une fois
l'autre jour Poutine il a dit le monde
sans les Russie ne manquerait pas quand
je raconte dans le livre je donne des
clés pour déchiffrer le personnage vous
comprenez je donne trois clés je tourne
la clé quand il est enfant abandonné et
je pense que la clé principale de sa
psychologie il était formé par la pègre
et dans la réalité c'est quelqu'un qui
est jusqu'au-boutiste dans la crise
aujourd'hui il est jusqu'au-boutiste il
ne recule pas il dit quand le bataille
est inévitable quand il était enfant il
a il était imprégné de cette culture il
se lance dans la bataille il va jusqu'au
bout l'enfant formé par la pègre ça
c'est la première que le deuxième clé
c'est la clé comment vous dire presque
sportif c'est un grand judoka il utilise
les gens au fait les adversaires sont la
force de l'adversaire pour remporter les
victoires bien sûr il est aussi joueur
d'échec comme tous les riches mais
au-delà de ça c'est surtout l'homme de
l'enseignement c'est une sorte de il se
prend pour un James Bond russe vous
comprenez ça c'est les choses comme ça
et il utilise la technique de
renseignement sur ce plan-là les
rapports de force mais quand il dit que
les Russie sent le monde sans la Russie
ne m'intéresse pas il faut il faut comme
je pense qu'il reflète le fond de sa
pensée et ça c'est c'est ça m'est vrai
vous comprenez ça veut dire qu'on est on
est possible
voilà jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire si mais il l'a dit hier
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout de la guerre
la guerre nucléaire et quand il parle
que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire l'entrée
mais vous comprenez la banalisation de
la guerre nucléaire chez les Américains
je sur les autres je suis effrayé par sa
déchirer je ne dors pas la nuit d'où mon
soutien passionné de la démarche
française je ne vous cache pas que vous
comprenez on la presta beaucoup sur ça
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de votes en
guerre j'ai remarqué une chose que je
tiens à vous signaler je me permets vous
comprenez hier tous ces gens-là ont été
spécialistes de covid aujourd'hui ils
sont tous spécialistes de l'Ukraine vous
comprenez et ces gens là ils sont très
militaires sont très modérés et dans ce
contexte là la démarche française est
très très importante vous avez un oral
là-bas les Français on aura
de Gaulle est à juillet là-bas
vous avez l'idée de l'Europe de
l'Atlantique à l'oral Mitterrand s'en
souvient de son idée de confédération
européenne en grandissent à faire
étrangères qui nous dit des choses très
censées Védrines par exemple etc Chirac
mon ami si on permettait quitter le
Sophie par excellence mais il me disait
souvent que l'avenir de l'Europe
vraiment l'Europe indépendante c'est
trois trois piliers c'est la France
c'est l'Allemagne et c'est la Russie
vous comprenez il y a encore peut-être
une petite possibilité et je pense
si on permettait à vos enfants et à mes
petites enfants comme je suis plus
expérimenté que ou que vous dans les
crises quand vous entendez Jean-Yves Le
Drian dire que la victoire finale sera
ukrainienne est-ce que vous partagez
cette analyse
vous savez bien sûr ça c'est un combo
je le faisceau le félicite de ces
paroles mais si on permettait une petite
suggestion quand j'étais impliqué
beaucoup de conversations on joue
maintenant perdant dans ces affaires il
faut trouver l'équilibre des intérêts le
mot que Mitterrand a aimé beaucoup quand
je lui disais ça l'équilibre des
intérêts c'est à dire il faut trouver
chacun vous comprenez qu'est-ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est un monde on va
aujourd'hui la nouvelle sanction ce sera
définitivement la rupture définitive
entre l'Europe et la Russie et dans la
réalité une constitution de blocs
Poutine a renforcer le temps le temps à
pousser le Poutine dans les bras chinois
alliance militaire et économique entre
la Chine et la Russie compétitive cette
guerre elle est en train de nouvelle
mais vous comprenez les gens sont avec
un nouveau clivage pour vous
de tous les dangers ce que
vous
les choses comme ça et l'Europe qui
pourquoi les américains sont très
contents pas parce que il y a des
milliards des milliards de dollars ont
passé ce jour-ci à cause de la crise
chez eux ils sont très contents pas
parce que ils vendent ils vendent le
pétrole 3 ou 4 fois pour le gaz de 4
fois gaz de schiste trois fois cher mais
parce que ils ont maintenant une
OTAN qui a le sens
vous savez encore où il y a quelques
temps Macron il a dit le temps c'est
c'est
la mort cérébrale qui peut dire ça
aujourd'hui non alors vous comprenez
mais simplement c'est pas mon monde j'ai
toute ma vie j'ai voulu le monde
équilibré j'ai voulu le monde c'est
beaucoup secure et je suis contre cette
guerre notamment il peut le faire venir
mais comprendre que l'équilibre des
intérêts et contrairement ce que pense
beaucoup de gens le rapport de force ne
jouons pas perdants perdants comme ça se
passe comme ça mais gagnant-gagnant
puisque vous le dit merci sera devant le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale en visio
cet après-midi il se sert beaucoup de
cette arme diplomatique de cette arme de
communication de devant les parlements
il va sûrement demander aux Européens
d'en faire encore plus les sanctions
elles vont avoir des conséquences sur
les peuples européens également est-ce
que vous redoutez une crise en Europe
c'est inévitable vous savez je ne
voudrais pas vous savez
je me retiens parfois des chaussures
parce que vous savez dire les réalités
puisqu'on posait la question c'est
inévitable parce que vous savez demain
on demande aujourd'hui on ferme le
robinet de pétrole les Russes finalement
ils vont fermer la robinet de gaz le gaz
du foie plus cher le choc pétrolier
la crise en Allemagne et ça contamine
l'Europe d'ailleurs c'est peut-être le
but de l'exercice je vous signale que
traditionnellement la crise il faut le
combattre avec deux moyens l'inflation
et la guerre cette fois-ci nous avons
quel visage pour vous et de quel ampleur
elle serait
apocalyptique je vous je vous dis c'est
possible que c'est la guerre soit
mondiale alors c'est pour d'où vient
vous savez dans la démarche de Macron et
de président Macron il y a une chose qui
est claire il est très clair par rapport
au crayon mon côté ukrainien il est
solidaire avec le peuple craignant et en
même temps si on permettait en même
temps il pousse cette arme diplomatique
et pour moi
c'est l'arme de l'avenir il faut savoir
sortir des guerres pensons en aux petits
enfants et à vos enfants et on va rester
sur ce mot merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité Vladimir fait
de rock ce qui je rappelle le titre de
votre livre qui sort donc aujourd'hui
Poutine l'Ukraine les fast cachées c'est
aux éditions ballon toutes les clés pour
toutes les clés pour déchiffrer notre la
crise et le monde qui nous attend
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]